Ça s'appelle AlterEgo.
C'est un appareil portable qui vous donne l'expérience d'une IA conversationnelle
qui habite dans votre tête,
à qui vous pouvez parler comme à vous-même.
En voici un prototype que nous présentons, ici,
pour la première fois à TED.
Voici comment il marche.
Normalement, quand nous parlons,
le cerveau envoie des signaux nerveux à travers les nerfs
aux systèmes de parole interne
pour les activer, ainsi que les cordes vocales, pour produire des sons.
C'est l'une tâches cognitives et motrices les plus complexes que l'humain fasse.
Imaginez parler à vous-même, sans un bruit, sans bouger votre bouche,
sans bouger votre mâchoire,
mais simplement en articulant ces mots intérieurement,
engageant ainsi très subtilement vos systèmes de parole interne,
comme votre langue et l'arrière de votre palais.
Si vous faites cela,
le cerveau envoie des signaux très faibles à ces systèmes de parole interne.
AlterEgo a des capteurs,
enveloppés dans un appareil en plastique fin, flexible et transparent
placé sur votre cou, comme un autocollant.
Ces capteurs recueillent ces signaux internes
puisés profondément dans la cavité buccale,
depuis la surface de la peau.
Un programme d'IA en arrière-plan
tente ensuite de comprendre ce que l'utilisateur veut dire.
Il répond ensuite à l'utilisateur en passant par la conduction osseuse,
le son étant amené par le crâne dans l'oreille interne de l'utilisateur,
que l'utilisateur entend,
en plus de ce qu'il entend naturellement de son environnement,
sans le bloquer.
La combinaison de toutes ces parties - ce qui entre, ce qui sort et l'IA -
permet une expérience subjective d'une interface dans votre tête
à qui vous pouvez parler comme si vous vous parliez à vous-même.
Pour être très clair, l'appareil n'enregistre ni ne lit vos pensées.
Il enregistre des informations que vous voulez communiquer
par l'engagement volontaire de vos systèmes internes de parole.
Les gens ne veulent pas être lus, ils veulent écrire.
Aussi, nous avons conçu le système
pour qu'il enregistre délibérément du système nerveux périphérique.
C'est pourquoi, l'utilisateur garde le contrôle dans toutes les situations.
Je veux m'arrêter là un instant et vous faire une démonstration.
Ce que je vais faire, c'est poser une question à Eric.
Et il va chercher cette information
sans articuler, sans taper, sans bouger ses doigts,
sans bouger sa bouche.
Simplement en posant la question intérieurement.
L'IA va ensuite trouver la réponse et la faire passer à Eric
par l'audio à travers l'appareil.
Certes, vous voyez un portable devant lui, mais il ne l'utilise pas.
Tout passe par l'appareil.
Seul l'appareil autocollant est nécessaire comme interface entre l'IA et internet.
Alors, Eric, quel temps fait-il à Vancouver en ce moment ?
Ce que vous voyez à l'écran,
ce sont les mots qu'Eric se dit à lui-même à l'instant présent.
Ça se passe en temps réel.
Eric : Il fait 10°C et il pleut, ici, à Vancouver.
Arnav Kapur : L'IA a envoyé la réponse
en audio en passant par l'appareil, à Eric.
Quelles conséquences cela peut-il avoir ?
Imaginez mémoriser parfaitement des choses,
en enregistrant des informations que vous pensez
et les écouter plus tard quand vous voulez,
chercher intérieurement des informations,
calculer des nombres à la vitesse d'un ordinateur,
envoyer des messages en silence,
devenir polyglotte d'un coup,
parler intérieurement dans une langue
et entendre la traduction dans votre tête.
Le potentiel est énorme.
Il y a des millions de gens à travers le monde
qui ont des difficultés à parler.
Des gens qui ont une SLA - la maladie de Charcot -
un AVC ou un cancer de la bouche, entre autres maladies.
Pour eux, communiquer est un processus laborieux et fatigant.
Voici Doug.
Doug souffre de SLA depuis 12 ans
et depuis il a perdu la capacité de parler.
Aujourd'hui, il tape sur un clavier visuel
les lettres une à une en utilisant des mouvements de tête.
Il lui faut plusieurs minutes pour communiquer une seule phrase.
Donc, nous avons demandé à Doug
quels étaient les premiers mots qu'il aimerait utiliser ou dire
en utilisant notre système.
Peut-être quelque chose comme : « Salut, ça va ? »
ou demander de l'aide.
Doug a dit qu'il voulait utiliser notre système
pour redémarrer son ancien système parce que ce dernier ne faisait que s'arrêter.
(Rires)
Nous n'aurions jamais pu prévoir cela.
Je vais vous montrer une vidéo de Doug
utilisant notre système pour la première fois.
(Voix) Redémarrer l'ordinateur.
Ce que vous venez d'entendre,
c'était Doug communiquant ou parlant en temps réel pour la première fois
depuis qu'il a perdu la parole.
Il y a des millions de gens
qui pourraient communiquer en temps réel comme Doug
avec d'autres personnes, leurs amis et leur famille.
J'espère pouvoir les aider à exprimer leurs pensées et leurs idées.
Je crois que les ordinateurs, l'IA et internet
disparaîtront en nous comme des extensions de notre cognition,
au lieu d'être des entités externes ou des adversaires
afin d'amplifier l'ingéniosité humaine,
nous donnant des capacités inimaginables et libérant notre vrai potentiel.
Et peut-être même nous permettant de devenir de meilleurs êtres humains.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Shoham Arad : Venez ici.
OK.
J'ai quelques questions pour vous pendant qu'ils rangent la scène.
Je trouve ça incroyable, c'est innovant,
c'est effrayant, c'est terrifiant.
Pouvez-nous nous dire ce que...
Je pense que ça génère des sentiments inconfortables.
Dites-nous, est-ce que ça lit nos pensées ?
Et dans cinq ans ?
Y a-t-il une version militaire ? A quoi ça ressemble ?
AK : Notre premier principe avant de travailler là-dessus
était de ne pas faire de l'éthique une réflexion après-coup.
Nous voulions intégrer l'éthique dès la conception.
Du coup,
au lieu de lire dans le cerveau, il lit le système nerveux somatique
qui doit être délibérément activé pour utiliser l'appareil,
tout en apportant les bénéfices d'un appareil pensant.
Le meilleur des deux, en quelque sorte.
SA : Je crois que les gens vont avoir encore plus de questions pour vous.
Vous disiez que c'est un autocollant.
Donc, pour l'instant, on le met là ?
Est-ce la dernière version,
ce à quoi le produit fini va ressembler ?
AK : Notre but est que la technologie disparaisse complètement.
SA : C'est-à-dire ?
AK : Si vous le portez, on ne devrait pas le voir.
Vous ne voulez pas l'avoir sur votre visage, mais en arrière-plan
pour vous augmenter en arrière-plan.
Nous avons une version autocollante qui s'adapte à la peau,
qui ressemble à la peau,
mais nous essayons de faire une version plus petite
qui se mettrait juste là.
SA : D'accord.
Je crois que si quelqu'un veut poser des questions à Arnav,
il sera là toute la semaine.
Merci beaucoup, Arnav.
AK : Merci, Shoham.